multiplication des manifestations
d'envergure à ces derniers jours en
grèce en cause le sort d'un prisonnier
en grève de la faim depuis cinquante
trois jours son nom dimitris couffo dina
sextape ensemble d'une organisation
terroriste d'ultragauche
le militant ans condamné à perpétuité
pour onze meurtres dans les années 70
dimitris couche au dinah se refuse
d'être réanimé si le gouvernement
conservateur refuse son transfert dans
une prison proche de sa famille
autrefois perçue comme l'ennemi public
numéro 1 d'athènes des milliers de
citoyens intellectuels avocats et même
juge vol aujourd'hui à son secours
dénonçant le non respect de l'état de
droit une situation qui divise le peuple
hélène selon jouait là d'allègre
spécialiste de la grèce est maître de
conférences émérite à l'inalco institut
national des langues et civilisations
orientales
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'héritage d'une question
essentielle puisque le mouvement du 17
novembre a commencé dans un contexte
particulier en 1975 et maintenant ça
recoupe une coupure nette entre gauche
et droite
si on veut vraiment être très très sain
le 17 novembre s'est tenue en souvenir
de la rétine sinueuses des colonels qui
avait envoyé des temps contre l'école
polytechnique à peine et le mouvement à
l'origine département terroristes qui
voulaient en fait je dirais pas refaire
d'injustice qui met un parent c'est
punir un certain nombre de gens qu'il
estimait avoir trop collaborer avec la
junte responsable de tout ce qui était
arrivé